I auditioned for Pulp Fiction and it was
no not Pulp Fiction I auditioned for
Reservoir Dogs
that was like a little late 80s did you
get it yeah I'm fantastic I'm gonna
watch that they did this head
replacement of Tim Roth on me it was
really pissed me off I didn't know I
went to the premiere and I was like oh
Tim Roth's head is on mine here's a Tim
Roth story wait I want to finish my
story oh I'm sorry I thought it was
ended I want to hear that you were
hoping uh yeah Sunrise is quick so I I
auditioned for Quentin Tarantino for
Quentin and and and and this is not an
imitation to Quinn but it he's a high
energy guy and he goes I I really like
what you do I I just don't know if I
want you to do it in my movie it was the
best rejection I ever got in my life
yeah yeah
I'm Roth we were at the
glows back in the 80s
and uh
sorry in the 90s because Mr Seinfeld
um
we were constantly uh getting losing at
the Golden Globes and um one particular
year they announced who's the winners
probably Frazier I can't really remember
and Tim Roth was at the table you know
at the Globes as people are drunk and so
uh all of a sudden Tim Ross stands up
and he goes you are [ __ ] robbed you
were [ __ ] robbed like that and I was
looking around it was just fantastic